manchmal hat die wissenschaft schon sehr
früh wichtige erkenntnisse gewonnen die
unumstößlich sind wie zum beispiel bei
der evolutionstheorie das was charles
darwin dort der vorstand oder die
physikalischen erkenntnissen von isaac
newton aber manchmal muss auch alles
wieder umgeworfen werden bei den
dinosauriern könnte das jetzt der fall
sein was ein britisches forscherteam im
wahrsten sinne des wortes
umstürzlerische herausgefunden hat dass
jetzt bei klick zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
die geschichte der dinosaurier muss
umgeschrieben werden ja und das ist
wirklich kein übertriebener quatsch wenn
es nach dem forscher team um matthew
waren von der renommierten englischen
university of cambridge geht dann muss
der stammbaum der dinosaurier
schlichtweg umgeschmissen werden er ist
falsch davon sind die wissenschaftler
überzeugt er war zu den dinosauriern sie
existiert ja schon vor rund 235
millionen jahren bis zu 66 millionen
jahre vor unserer zeit also ein
vielfaches mehr als wir quasi unfasslich
viel mehr als die menschen mehr
existiert nämlich so etwa 2000 jahre
also oft das alter der erde von 4,6
milliarden jahren lächerlich lang da
haben die dinos von etwas mehr zu bieten
die forscher unterschiede bisher zwei
gruppen die vogel becken dinosaurier und
die echsen becken dinosaurier schon da
liegt der hase im pfeffer
denn die vogelbeckensaurier gelten als
viel benannt bisher waren die forscher
der ansicht die vögel stammen vom
theropoden einer unterart der echsen
becken dinosaurier ab zu denen zum
beispiel der tyrannosaurus rex gehört
aber jetzt wird alles anders
wenn die forscher recht haben was ist
also geschehen die forscher hatten
übereinstimmung der dinos über die
verschiedenen erste der dino stammbäume
selbst gestellt und wurden stutzig wie
können sich - ähnlich sein die
eigentlich aus einer ganz anderen linie
des stammbaumes stamm was machen
forscher in einem solchen fall wie
forschen hier haben sie einfach wieder
bei null angefangen und 74 saurierarten
erneut umfangreiche analyse fehler 750
anatomische merkmale haben wir dabei
detailliert angeschauten dabei
erstaunliches zutage fördert nämlich
alles ist anders die theropoden wird
einfach falsch eingeordnet 21 merkmale
ihres gesetz stimmen nicht mit den
echsen becken sondern mit den vogel
becken dinosauriern über 1 das ist auch
dass vogel paradoxon endlich während die
vögel mit den vogelbeckensaurier
verwandt und nicht mit den exakten
dinosauriern zitat die auswirkungen
dieser neuen sichtweise sind so
überraschend wie tiefgreifend denn jetzt
sind die vogel becken dinosaurier
erstmals direkt mit den vorfahren der
heute lebenden vögel verknüpft so
koautor david normen von der university
of cambridge aber gibt noch zwei neue
thesen der neuen kino studien die nuss
existieren schon seit 247 millionen
jahren also etwas länger
und sie sind nicht auf dem südlichen
teil des rückens kontinent gondwana
sondern auf dem nördlichen teil
laura entstanden zitat 130 jahre lang
hatten paläontologen eine bestimmte
vorstellung von der theologie der
dinosaurier
doch unsere forschung spricht dafür dass
wir die evolutionäre geschichte dieser
kreaturen neu betrachten müssen so der
forscher wenn unser vorschlag die
akademische prüfung übersteht dann
müssen alle wichtigen lehrbücher neu
geschrieben werden könnte also
tatsächlich passieren dass unsere
lehrbücher umgeschrieben werden müssen
die methodik der arbeit wird jedenfalls
nicht in zweifel gezogen sondern ihr
wird von kollegen absolut seriöse geht
bescheinigt jetzt gilt es allerdings die
studie durch weitere vorziehen analysen
zu bestätigen oder eben nicht warnten
jetzt müssen echte bücher umgeschrieben
werden wenn das so stimmt den satz sagt
man wirklich selten die geschichte der
dinosaurier muss umgeschrieben werden
spektakulär spektakulären videos gibt es
übrigens ihr best of tricks um unbedingt
ansehen also drauf klicken und wenn ihr
kein video mehr verpassen wollt dank
drückt man hier ein abo aufs auge
einfach klicken und vergesst nicht wir
danach einen auf die glocke zu geben
ansonsten bis dann bleibt kann